well on monday every nevadan 16 or older
will be able to get a covet vaccine in
the meantime many are already getting
their second dose
madison kimbrough is at the convention
center live with us with an update hey
madison
yes health officials say that our cases
are staying
stable excuse me but also made and
wanted to reiterate the fact that we are
not
done fighting this virus we spoke to a
couple people here
at the convention center that really got
their second dose today and were very
happy about it happy about the process
they said was much
easier than their first seeing declines
in our cases but the trend is currently
very stable overall
and the trend is not very concerning to
the state team at this time
the state's positivity rate over the
last 14 days is now at 4.2 percent
but nevada's covet 19 response director
caleb cage says just because we're under
the 5 percent mark
doesn't mean we are home free while we
are hopeful
that the consequences are lower because
of the introduction of the tool of the
vaccine
it's extremely important to remember
that
the vaccine is only one of the tools
that we have
that we have the statewide mask mandate
that the governor has kept in place even
after may 1st
that means wear your mask continue to
maintain your distance and wash your
hands often
today over at the health district all
clinical services including covet 19
vaccines
were canceled due to a leak of their
water boiler while repairs are underway
the district encouraged those to head
over to both the cashmen center and
convention center
to fulfill their appointments a process
many said was quick
and painless there's no waiting at all i
walked right through they got me
all the way through i sat down i got the
shot i barely felt it
and many people we spoke to at the
convention center believe that now as
people are getting their second doses
the process has become easier the second
time around is a lot faster in
and out the first time we had it that
wait was a little bit longer
it's more organization that's what
that's what's making the difference i
think they're getting better
and better are moving doing it faster
and starting monday all nevadans 16 and
up will be eligible to get their
vaccination
now 32.4 percent of the population that
is 16 and up
have already initiated vaccinations
that's very good news
reporting live at the convention center
madison kimbrough 8 news now